I was played back in 2009 US Open in
Indianapolis I was 15 years old at the
time I was still under 2,200 was when I
crossed the 2200 mark to become a
national master and it was a really good
tournament for me as a nine round event
big open section earlier in the
tournament
I drew Grandmaster Jesse cry that was my
first time ever drawing a Grand Master
in a tournament game so that was
exciting and then this game happened I'm
playing John Fedora whit's
the day before he was or the day before
we played this game he was inducted into
the world at the world chess Hall of
Fame I think it was a US chess Hall of
Fame so it was a huge moment for him and
but he wasn't having the best event and
I remember when he came to the game he
just looked tired I think he was
probably up late the night before and
then we played the game he was white
I'll just go through it's relatively
short game and a little bit of time to
prepare beforehand so I was expecting
this Queens gambit declined exchange
variation and this was all all theory
and then this is this position I was
expecting Queen f3 it's a main line
where it usually leads to a very quiet
position Bishop g6 Bishop take f6 guess
I could play this out it's pretty
typical line which okay this has
happened numerous times before so I was
expecting kind of a lon
middle game endgame grind but then he
surprised me instead of playing Queen f3
he played pawn g4 it kind of came out of
nowhere and it was my first time
actually seeing this type of move of
course when you see this move the first
thing you have to ask yourself is can
you take on g4 which an answer is no
black cannot take on g4 because of fish
at take f6 and white just wins a piece
so I played Bishop e6 he played h3 wait
velop and he was playing super
aggressively f4 threatening f5 but i saw
the threat I played Knight b6 and like
okay this position actually looks ok for
whites and quite controls a lot of space
and scary when you're black and you're
playing a grandmaster and they were just
controlling so much space but the thing
to realize is sometimes whites a bit
overextended in these cases and I guess
he was provoked to overextend even
further now when I played Queen d6 my
main intention was to prevent him from
playing f5 but he played a5 anyway
and then I took a long think because I
was conflicted whether or not to play
Queen g3 which was my original intention
but I went ahead and played it and then
he ran away and then I played this move
Knight e4 which just made everything
really crazy and it took me a long time
to play Knight e4 too because just so
many things are happening in this
position bishops tearing each other my
bishop attacks so many pieces directed
at you for potential to attack his King
even further and it kind of hurt my head
it was also the last round so we were
both tired but I think his mistake from
this position he was just moving too
quickly I don't think he saw ok as we'll
see he didn't see some basic tactics he
took on e4 I take he takes and then
Queen f2 and this was a moment he
justified way too quickly there's only
one good move for a white here I think
during the game I was hoping for
something like Queen e2 and then I have
some nice Knight c4 move and then I take
b2 with the Queen defending via x-ray
vision then Bishop b4 and that would
this is just winning a queen for black
but he didn't play Queenie - he played
an even worse move
he played King c3 such a bad move and
this is where I would say like okay if
this is on YouTube which I'm probably
going to upload this to YouTube so for
the YouTube viewers who didn't cheat and
see the notation even for the twitch
viewers to feel free to pause and find
the best move for black the winning move
for black this is this is probably the
move that he just overlooked so black to
move and win and I'll show it once
someone says it in the chat Keith
Patrick saw it - what a cheater
that was my fault for not putting on
training mood earlier ok deaf dog deaf
dog has found it yeah Bishop b4 check
bishop take g5 bishop take g5 is
interesting but it just leads to trades
Bishop b4 is just crushing and then he
just resigned like he'd barely even
thought before resigning I was just in
shock at first victory over a GM like I
was black 16 moves so it was a good
experience and this game was broadcast
via Monroy it's like the maybe the newer
players don't know what Monroy is but it
was like the first broadcasting system
so people were watching online and a lot
of people thought I was like a bug in
the system that this could actually
happen but but yeah I was nice good
memories if he takes on b4
I'm just taking on b2 if King a5 Queen
b5 mates if king c5 I could play Queen
a3 which is made immediately but maybe I
would play Queen B 5 and then Knight c8
and then make his King walk all the way
into my crib and then probably play
Queen b6 mates
which would be a hilarious finish uh but
yeah that was fun
so anyway I'll probably I'll probably
make a clip out of this and put it on
YouTube that's what I did for the last
stream so for the YouTube audience who's
watching hope you guys enjoy that if you
have any questions just let me know in
the chat and and I'll see you guys in
the next video